enfin marvel nous a dévoilé la phase iv
et les premiers films qui la composeront
et c'est un truc de ouf je suis trop
hype et à l'heure actuelle oblige et
qu'on en fasse une vidéo et qu'on en
parle ensemble
alors c'est parti lors du marvel
entertainment nous avons le privilège
dans l'ordre de sortie des films de
commencer par black widow alors c'était
très prévisible et nous le savions déjà
depuis un petit moment
le film sur les origines de black widow
sera le premier film à ouvrir la phase
iv et sortira le 1er mai 2020 néanmoins
ce ne sera pas un film aussi bateau
qu'on pourrait le penser
déjà le casting amène beaucoup de
nouvelles têtes pour ce film comme
notamment david harbour dans le rôle
d'alexis le gardien rouge trop content
de le voir dans du marvel ou encore le
personnage de jelena belova incarné par
florence bugs
bref d'autres espions russes seront
présents en gros le film se passera donc
après civil war à notre plus grande
surprise
effectivement nous pensions voir un film
sur l'enfance et l'adolescence de black
widow sur comment est-elle devenue
espionne
mais non cela dit civil war a permis à
beaucoup de héros de revenir sur leur
origine et refaire ce qu'il faisait de
mieux c'est le cas avec natacha cette
dernière devra normalement affronter
taskmaster un vilain devenu une sorte
d'anti héros dans les comics ce dernier
a la particularité d'avoir un don
photographique en recopiant le style de
combat de chaque héros par une brève
observation ce qui est très intrigant et
que ce film sera normalement le dernier
où nous verrons scarlett johansson et il
est apparemment dit qu'un personnage
pourrait la remplacer
il est évident que ce film bien qu'il se
passe dans le passé pourrait amener une
problématique pour le futur du mc eu
soit dans le présent par le biais d'une
scène post-générique par exemple ou tout
simplement la fin du film taskmaster
pourrait être celui qui prendrait en
quelque sorte la place du personnage
étant dans les comics un ennemi qui
retournera sa veste pour au final finir
mercenaires mais la vie qu'une femme
espionne remplace black widow ne
m'étonnerait pas 1re série à être
développé sur dix n'est plus qu'en est
il de ce falcon and the winter soldier
paramètres ultra intéressant marvel
s'ouvre enfin aux séries de véritables
série avec les acteurs du mc hugh
baignant à 100% dans l'univers
cinématographique de marvel développer
le mc eu en série également va permettre
de développer énormément
chose que ce soit sur le background des
personnages l'univers ou tout autre nous
retrouverons bien évidemment bucky le
winter soldier et samaa cas le faucon ou
bien le nouveau captain america ce
nouveau duo fera notamment face à un
ennemi déjà connu le baron zemo soit
celui qui créa la discorde entre les
avengers en civil war l'idée de la série
est très pertinente car elle permettra
de montrer l'évolution du personnage du
faucon en tant que captain america il se
pourrait même d'ailleurs que nous
revoyons steve à certains moments de la
série j'en suis certain le seul bémol
pour moi est que cette série tout comme
les autres ont été créés principalement
pour développer 10 n'est plus ce qui
veut dire qu'elles n'ont pas forcément
d'impact à la base espérons que je me
trompe et que marvel ne nous dit pas
comme il aurait pu le faire avec la
version longue date game alors je ne
vous cache pas que y est un hall se doit
être l'un des films qui m'intrigue le
plus car je connais très peu ses rôles à
marvel ne rigole pas et amène de
nombreux nouveaux super héros pour la
phase iv et qui ont beaucoup de
potentiel pour la suite avec un futur
beaucoup plus orienté cosmique que
therrien par rapport à la phase 3 les
éternels ont été conçus par les célestes
comme le père de coups il par exemple
donc d être extrêmement puissant c'est
céleste ont pris des hommes normaux pour
en faire des surhommes qui sont donc
devenus les éternels pas de milly bobby
brown pour ceux qui l'espéraient mais
une angelina jolie ou encore un richard
madden sans parler de tous les autres
le film est prévue pour le 6 novembre
2020 et ce qui m'intrigue réellement est
le fait d'intégrer un nouveau groupe en
concurrence avec les gardiens de la
galaxie en quelque sorte dans le mc eu
j'admets ne pas trop connaître ses euros
mais ils formeront forcément une sorte
de groupe mais avec des pouvoirs
extrêmement puissant des pouvoirs
cosmiques psychique et surtout une
longévité incroyable
au point d'être des immortels ce sera
intéressant de pouvoir les comparer à
captain marvel dans l'avenir en tout cas
je me demande si ce film ne sera pas une
sorte de rapprochement avec celui de
docteur strange effectivement docteur
strange prendra du multiverse de la
folie dans sa traduction et les
éternelles du alors malédiction lancée
par les célestes possède une sorte de
folie qui se développe en eux dû à leur
grand pouvoir dans le corps de simples
mortels
peut-être ai-je tort mais je suis très
curieux de voir ce que ça donnera
et s'il ya un rapport justement avec le
père de quinn passe
maintenant hâte shanxi je ne vais pas
vous le cacher c'était soit lui soit
nova pour moi d'après toutes les rumeurs
qu'on voyait circuler et quelle belle
surprise shanxi
ces genres le pro du combat au corps à
corps et des arts martiaux
le film sort le 12 février 2021 et
propose six mots liot dans le rôle
principal
nous savons que le méchant sera donc le
mandarin chef de l'organisation
terroriste des dix anneaux c'est
d'ailleurs cette même organisation qui
avait à la base
enlevez tony stark dans son premier film
je suis vraiment très curieux de voir ce
héros personnellement car il ne possède
pas spécialement de grands pouvoirs à
part ces arts martiaux c'est un terrien
que prévoit marvel pour la suite avec un
héros comme ça au milieu des éternels
par exemple zhang chi a fait partie des
nouveaux avenger dans les comics et il
est possible que ce soit une route que
marvel souhaite prendre
tony lui avait d'ailleurs confectionné
une tenue appropriée à ces arts martiaux
se pourrait-il que spider man en fasse
de même du coup je me demande d'ailleurs
si hawkeye n'affrontait pas
l'organisation des designers justement
dans endgame peut-être qu'il y ait un
rapprochement à faire
nous arrivons maintenant à oujda vision
et wow c'est une grande surprise la
série était attendue et prévue mais ce
qui me hype c'est qu'elle se passe après
les événements des avengers endgame ce
qui veut dire que c'est confirmé vision
sera bel et bien de retour et
certainement grâce à xuri prévu pour
j'avoue que l'on sait très peu de choses
sur cette série on sait que monica rambo
la fille de maria rambo la copine d'armé
et de captain marvel sera justement dans
la série mais du coup en version adulte
car depuis captain marvel
elle aurait du coup environ 40 ans et je
suis très curieux de voir son rôle dans
la série
il se pourrait que marvel prépare une
nouvelle héroïne du nom de spectrum et
du coup l'incarnation de monica rambo
nous pourrons suivre l'évolution
amoureuse du couple luanda et visions et
j'ai vraiment ultra de voir ce que ça
donnerait mai
je n'espère pas une série comédie
romantique mais là où c'est intéressant
c'est que cette série aurait apparemment
un lien avec le film de doctor strange
qui se passe bizarrement juste après la
série alors docteur strange tiens voilà
le film que j'attends le plus dans cette
nouvelle phase de marvel prévu pour le 7
mai 2021 nous retrouverons bien
évidemment le docteur strange qui fera
normalement face a nightmare et sa
dimension cauchemar comme on l'avait
déjà supposé auparavant ce qui est très
intrigant en revanche est la présence de
wendat dans le film incarné par
elisabeth owen il est clair que le
personnage de webdav a clairement évolué
le mc eu est très loin de nous avoir
montré tout le potentiel du personnage
elle qui d'après moi est l'une des
avengers les plus puissantes dans les
comics quoi de mieux qu introduire le
multiverse avec notre cher docteur il
est le plus légitime d'introduire les
dimensions mais chose intéressante c'est
encore scott derrickson le réalisateur
du film et suite au premier docteur
strange ce dernier avait affirmé qu'il
cherchait un moyen d'inclure cléa à
l'écran pour le deuxième opus léa et
l'amour du docteur strange est la nièce
de dormammu si le personnage de
christine palmer n'est pas prévu il se
pourrait que cette dernière du coup
fasse son apparition
l'eau qui va être une série que je vais
beaucoup attendre car je suis très
curieux tom hiddleston a confirmé que la
série se passerait suite aux évènements
d'un game où ce dernier a réussi à
s'échapper avec le tesseract je suis
très curieux de savoir ce qu'ils vont
nous proposer car il ya mille et une
possibilités de chemin pour l'eau qui
déjà nous serons dans le passé est une
autre réalité que celle que nous
connaissons donc l'eau qui ne sera pas
face aux mêmes tort que nous connaissons
ou les autres héros ce qui veut dire
qu'il est possible que marvel remodèle
tout suite aux actions de l'eau qui dans
cette dimension est ce que ce dernier
ira donner le tc wright à thanos
possible mais à cette période du 1er à
20 heures le lot qui était encore très
perfide peut-être évoluera-t-il et c'est
ce que marvel veut nous montrer son
développement et une autre vision de
loki concept très pertinent nous
arrivons à la série animée et what if
prévu par marvel l'idée est très simple
vous prenez une idée est faite une
histoire par rapport à ça genre et si
thanos avait tué tony stark sur titan
quelle serait la suite et ses
conséquences je prends personnellement
comme un bonus
peu que l'animé est un rapport avec des
dimensions comme pour spider man into
the spider verse mais de gros gros
moyens seront mis dans la série dont la
voix des acteurs originaux des
personnages comme josh brolin alias
thanos par exemple ou le retour du
personnage de hank pym où la voix de
samuel jackson et j'en passe bref je
n'ai pas grand chose à dire dessus ce
serait je pense une petite fraîcheur
pour l'été 2021 du coup trois séries
d'affilée marvel ne perd pas son temps
et souhaite vraiment promouvoir disney +
nouvelle série de prévu aux cayes
c'est une bonne option pour ok car je ne
voyais vraiment plus d'avenir pour le
héros à part sa vie de famille
mais c'est ce qu'il se passera du coup
la série va introduire l héroïne kate
bishop la fille de hawkeye formé par ses
soins et qu'on a déjà vu au début de
ngame cette dernière continuera à
prendre le tir à l'arc avec son père et
risque de remplacer ce dernier au fil du
temps la relève est vraiment là et ça
fait très très bizarre
nous sommes réellement dans une nouvelle
ère des héros de marvel on arrive enfin
à la plus grosse surprise de toutes les
annonces et certainement le plus gros
film de ce début de phase 4 thor 4 love
and thunder avec le retour de natalie
portman en mighty thor une tort au
féminin c'est tout bonnement incroyable
et ça promet du lourd
vraiment un couple de héros surpuissant
la puissance de thor est phénoménal et
si en plus ce jane se met à le rejoindre
ça va être un truc de fou ce qui
m'intrigue en revanche c'est que
valkyrie sera de la partie aussi et jane
est normalement une terrienne
alors qu'est ce qui va pousser tort à
revenir sur terre retrouver sa nouvelle
à ce garde qui l'a pourtant laissé à
walkyrie justement et qu'en est il des
gardiens qu'il était censé accompagner
et dont le film est en développement
pour le moment tout ceci est très
étrange notamment par rapport à ce qui
était montré à la fin d une game en tout
cas vu l'importance et l'annoncent forte
de ce film il se pourrait qu'un méchant
redoutablement puissant soit annoncée
dans ce film est peut-être pour
l'ensemble de la phase 4
et puis on termine avec blade annoncé
dans les mc une très grande surprise par
rapport à cette annonce également mais
nous ne savons trop rien sur ce film
pour le moment nous savons également que
blake panthères 2 est en développement
ainsi que captain marvel de et les
gardiens la galaxy 3 qui sera je pense
l'un des films les plus importants
notamment par rapport à
adam warlock marvel nous promet du lourd
evans est normalement de nouveaux super
héros dont probablement les nouveaux
avengers
j'ai vraiment hâte et comptez sur moi
pour vous faire des théories il est
possible qu'on parle de doctor strange
prochainement rendez-vous maintenant en
août pour la d23 expo où nous aurons de
nouvelles informations concernant la
tournure de la phase 4
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner me suivre
sur twitter ou instagram que le live
earth soit avec vous c'était targo rock
[Musique]